what is a zero-day vulnerability
and then um a zero-day exploit or attack
so
at the most basic level let's say i'm a
hacker and i find a bug in your iphone
ios software that no one else knows
about especially apple
that's called a zero day because the
minute it's discovered engineers have
had zero days to fix it
if i
can study that zero day i could
potentially write a program to exploit
it
and that program would be called a zero
day exploit
and for ios the dream
is that you craft a zero day exploit
that can remotely exploit someone else's
iphone without them ever knowing about
it and you can capture their location
you can capture
their contacts that record their
telephone calls record their camera
without them knowing about it
basically you can put an invisible ankle
bracelet
on someone without them knowing and you
can see why that capability that zero to
exploit would have immense value
for a spy agency or a government that
wants to monitor its critics or
dissidents
and so there's a very lucrative market
now for zero day exploits so you said a
few things there one is ios why ios why
which operating system which one is the
sexier thing to try to get to or the
most impactful thing
and uh the other thing you mentioned is
remote
versus like having to actually come in
physical contact with it is that the
distinction
so
iphone
exploits have just been a government's
number one
priority
recently actually the price of an
android remote zero day exploit
something that can get you into android
phones
is actually higher the value of that is
now higher on this underground market
for zero day exploits than an iphone ios
exploit so things are changing so the
there's probably more android devices so
that's why it's better
but then the iphone side
if i so i'm an android person
because i'm a man of the people
but it seems like all the elites use
iphone all the people at nice dinner
parties so
uh is that is that the reason that like
the more powerful people use iphones is
that why i don't think so i actually so
it was about two years ago that the
prices flipped it used to be
that if you could craft a remote
zero click
exploit for ios
then that was about as good as it gets
you could sell that
to a zero-day broker
for two million dollars
the caveat is you can never tell anyone
about it because the minute you tell
someone about it apple learns about it
they patch it and that 2.5 million
dollar investment that that zero day
broker just made goes to dust
so a couple years ago
and don't quote me on the prices but
an android zero click
remote exploit for the first time topped
the ios and actually a lot of people's
read on that
was that it might be
a sign that apple security
was falling
and that it might actually be easier
to find
an ios zero day exploit than find an
android zero to exploit the other thing
is market share
there are just more people around the
world that use android
and a lot of governments that are paying
top dollar for zero day exploits these
days
are deep pocketed governments in the
gulf
that want to use these exploits to
monitor their own citizens monitor their
critics
and so it's not necessarily that they're
trying to find elites
it's that they want to find out who
these people are that are criticizing
them or perhaps planning the next arab
spring
so in your experience are most of these
attack targeted to cover a large
population or is there
attacks that are targeted towards
specific individuals
so i think it's both
some of the zero day exploits that have
fetched top dollar
that i've heard of in my reporting in
the united states were highly targeted
you know there was a potential terrorist
attack they wanted to get into this
person's phone it had to be done in the
next 24 hours they approached hackers
and say we'll pay you
x millions of dollars if you can do this
but then you look at
when we've discovered ios zero day
exploits in the wild
some of them have been targeting large
populations like uyghurs
so a couple years ago there was a
watering hole attack okay it's a
watering hole attack there's a website
it was actually it had information
aimed at uyghurs and you could access it
all over the world
and if you visited this website
it would drop
an ios zero to exploit onto your phone
and so anyone that visited this website
that was about uyghurs anywhere i mean
uyghurs
uyghurs living abroad basically the
uyghur diaspora
would have gotten infected with this
zero-day exploit so in that case you
know they were targeting
huge swaths of this one population or
people interested in this one population
basically in real time
you